was that surprising to see such a
sell-off
well it wasn't that surprising because
people are expect he's such a big person
in the market I mean a 222 billion
dollar Fund in a market that doesn't
trade that frequently where there isn't
that much turnover you're going to see
some uh some trading around that people
are wondering whether the firm is going
to change its strategy uh they're
wondering whether the outflows are going
to force selling that could you know
potentially affect uh to affect asset
prices and the interesting thing is
while the most liquid or the most
frequently traded acids bounced back the
less frequently traded assets did not so
uh you know one of the fascinating
things is just the big run-up that we
saw in Janus I mean the biggest gain in
that company stock price ever getting a
bill grossen house I think people wanted
to take advantage there were a lot of
people looking for different ways to
kind of capitalize on this and to make
some fast money off of it that being
said I think you're right there's some a
lot of the things just bounced right
back and I think to me this kind of
illustrates the resilience of the bond
market and that it's you know you have
the biggest move in probably you know
definitely 2014 in a couple years and
yet everything kind of came back and I
think what happened was there was so
much speculation but Pimco saying you
know we're not changing any strategies
we've had redemptions for 16 consecutive
months this isn't new to us we know how
to handle this we have liquidity you
know and people in the market trying to
position around it do you think they
anticipated this much though
I don't think they were anticipating
much I don't think they were prepared
for this I don't mean they were prepared
as far as who would come in and step in
but I don't think that they were
expecting him to resign I don't know if
you're in-house for the past few months
you're sitting there and you're saying
this situation is deteriorating this is
getting worse and worse if I'm Dan
Iverson and I'm threatening to quit you
know that something's coming so either
way you slice it either I'm out the door
Bill's out the door something's gonna
happen and it's going to be a little bit
disruptive it didn't disappear seem as
though it was resolved when Muhammad
left though I mean it seemed as though
okay well Bill gross is there to stay
they had their battle he you know
Muhammad left bill was there so you know
for him to suddenly now take off and go
to Janice it seemed as though he had
already gotten the endorsement of the
board but I think that was really the
final blow right so you have a structure
that really works when you have an
authoritarian figure that he really kept
a tight hold on everything and everyone
and everyone knew that right and so the
minute that his authority was undermined
and he lost the performance track record
for a little bit he lost the kind of
credibility externally and it's not so
much that people smelled blood so much
as you just said okay this this rain is
kind of over and this these very
competitive very ambitious Traders and
portfolio managers kind of saw an
upwards so what happens to Pimco now
a lot well I think from the bond markets
perspective people are really trying to
look at the flows they're trying to
figure out where the money is going to
go how much they're actually going to
have to liquidate I know that a lot of
other investment managers have taken on
uh assets and mandates to manage those
assets directly from Pimco which is sort
of mitigated some of the effects in the
market because I haven't had to actually
sell those assets the question in the
bond market is going forward will they
have to Boost Force you know will they
be forced to actually sell some of the
underlying assets what will that do to
the market how will they manage going
forward will they really keep his uh
Bill gross strategies in place
you know it doesn't look like it worked
for them though that's the reality right
so maybe it's not worth keeping his
strategies in place they're saying you
know we're keeping all of the same
strategies all of the same processes all
the infrastructure but you kind of want
them to address that the performance
hasn't been up to par so can we actually
change some things and maybe get
performance back